thank you
hey everybody and welcome to a fiery
wild ride with Stevo we've got Flames to
put out folks there was an issue between
me and Andrew Santino and we dived right
into that and man is it juicy what a
hilarious guy speaking of fire the guy
is on fire man filming Big Time movies
with Zac Efron and John Cena right now
and boy does he dish up the goods about
that I'm telling you you guys are gonna
love this one so let's get into it
ladies and gentlemen
Andrew Santino
and the conference room goes wild we
made it it's been a long time coming
yeah I've reached out to Andrew Santino
um I don't know how many times too many
um and uh every time I asked can can you
do my podcast I'll bring it to you it'll
be so easy
um it was uh
man I got too much going on uh like and
it got to a point where I was so
frustrated that I lashed out in the most
humiliating way it was very funny yeah
you should put the tech stuff on the we
should make t-shirts of what he said to
you [__] you bro
and I legitimately was like is this for
real immediately it's a comic you're
like there's a bit he's doing a bit and
I was about to go [__] you bro I'm like
no no he's mad I could I was like no
he's actually frustrated my favorite
part about that whole thing is he said
eat [__] eat [__]
fast I misspelled to eat [__] your anger
restricts you from actually getting the
the diss out
and then you said yeah I'm gonna go eat
[__] yeah
I can feel my face getting red
um but here's the thing I've never heard
Steve talk like that in my life that's
why when he when he was like dude and I
was like bro let's let's get out of here
let's go somewhere it
often the case it had nothing to do with
with you no no I knew that like I was uh
I've been a comic for 20 years like I
get it by now yeah when when you when I
fight with Bobby when when I get into it
with any friends in our world I know
right away what's really going on it's
some other [__] you're fried it's a
relationship you're tired it's uh family
[__] it's dude it's always everything
else I bur and I bur one time
Burr one time and I had a little thing
and it wasn't a big deal but
I was bummed I was like really hurt
because I look up to him I respect him
like he's a hero oh yeah and then he
something happened it's no money's
business but it was like it bummed me
out
and then a couple days later he texted
me because he's like the greatest dude
on Earth and was like I'm sorry man I
didn't I don't know why I said that I
don't know why this went this way but he
was like
straight up it's you know it's because
of XYZ and he explained to me like what
was going on I was like oh good I got it
I didn't take it as
me right I knew some other [__] was up
and he was like that had nothing to do
with you yeah but for some reason you
were [__] in the line of fire and you
got clipped and I was like it happened
it's I let that stuff go so fast dude it
goes away it's like my dad I grew up in
a world of lies and Chaos of my dad was
a drug addict and not a prison who never
showed up but said he was going to show
up so I always know about the other side
of it where like something else is going
on yeah definitely I had but you showed
up to him for to for today for me dad
you were here
fortunately I I uh I came around pretty
quickly and and no you did it was good I
acknowledged where I had come up short
yeah but did your dad ever tell you to
eat [__] he would he would finish it
he'd say eat [__] I uh I was typing so
fast and and I wrote eat
s-h-i-y I misspelled it and just and it
was already sent yeah each eye is kind
of a cool and then he sent it again yeah
oh I misspelled to eat [__] twice yeah
yeah
you should make each guy shirts I wanted
to make a text bubble that said eat shy
and do like like something drop each eye
yeah but you're here and we're here and
we took us to go to Australia the truth
is the truth is I have been draining
myself to a degree I can't even explain
it's been the last three months of my
life four months have been gross two and
it's gonna get worse it's gonna get
worse can you talk about what you're
doing yeah yeah I'm doing here shooting
a movie it's all over the [__] papers
it was crazy being down in Australia
shooting a movie with Zac Efron and
because he's so famous
you forgot that like in America
famous whatever we live in LA we see
famous people it doesn't mean anything
uh it does dude here it's here it's it's
different different why what does he do
when he goes out we can't go out we have
to we have to get private tables
everywhere we have to like when we do go
out together we have to be like it's
discreet it's tough dude it's really
tough it's just so hard you have to like
dude there the paparazzi are like
everywhere they find sneaky little ways
to find out where the production is
shooting all and dude we're everywhere
we're not in one spot we're we'll travel
you know 20 kilometers Mike to go to
this [__] place they'll find a way
there
they're always around bothering sneaking
and it's just it's it's we it's creepy
dude it's creepy is he hotter in real
life or in the movies
he's pretty damn he's pretty hot he's
pretty hot he's pretty hot and Cena and
then Cena's with us so John is super
famous too you know and that's another
level of like crazy super Fame it's like
it's it's strange it's like who's more
famous Cena or Ephron when you guys go
out two totally different worlds yeah
like two like like that's what I think
is good about the movie it's like
pulling from two different fan bases
Cena's like uh
seen as bro more bro bro famous and
Efron is way more chick famous Wow way
more chicks are going to come up and
the bar aren't going to be like Zach
but dudes but dudes me and uh when Cena
was here he's gone but when he was here
we did my podcast and then we went out
and had
um he was afterwards I was like well
let's get you back to your to your wife
you know he want to go back to the hotel
he was like you know dude I just texted
her do you want to go get a Guinness he
likes he like the boy likes his Guinness
and I was like I'd love to go get a
Guinness and attacked this guy and I
said what's the best place to get a
Guinness and he said you should go get
Guinness at this spot and they have good
kangaroo so me and Cena lit up a bunch
of guinnesses and had kangaroo wow it's
dude it's it's rad it's like elk meat
it's super it's gamey it's lean but it's
good yeah wow you should dude have you
never had it I I only eat seafood I
haven't oh you don't need meat at all
right anything but Seafood in a long
time dude take your ass to go get some
kangaroo I'll eat some kangaroo it's it
honestly I thought it was gonna be the
woman at the bar was like if you don't
like it we'll you know toss it off the
bill and I was like yeah I'll try it I
loved it finished it I was like this is
delicious yeah so good dude I think it's
really if you like gamey stuff if you
can handle it but he likes his Guinness
and so he had a bunch of those but he
sat at the bar
nobody really bothered him
uh a few people came over one [__]
came over you know like the absolute
[__] move we all know the move is
like Steve Steve I'm a huge fan thanks
man thanks man all right man [__]
love you and then what that's it that's
cool but this guy's on FaceTime with his
homie drunk and he's like [__] John
Cena mate [__] John Cena and John
politely was like Hey man come on come
on dude that could have been a dick like
he could have grabbed his phone and been
like dude you know embarrassed him but
he was like come on dude be cool about
it man well yeah and he pulled him aside
and was like I'll do a photo but you
know don't do that it was like the
classiest version of
you know telling this guy don't be a
[__] idiot at the bar and call more
attention to me but he can go out Zach
can't really go out I mean he can I
guess but I don't know he chooses not to
it's uh let's get his dick sucked all
day he that's what he's doing he's got
his dick he's got a rotating list yeah
yeah shifts everyone's taking shifts
okay tip in tap out now how long have
you been in Australia you said a month
and a half I got here January at the end
of January I don't even remember and and
um it's not what is it March mid-march
or something since it's May yeah June
you banged a bunch of episodes of your
podcasts ahead of time I did as many as
I could and then I did a bunch here you
know Jimmy Carr came through yeah um
Russell Peters was supposed to do it but
he bailed Russell eat [__]
he came and he came and played the uh he
played the John Kane Arena uh right
across the street you know like right
around that way unbelievable the tickets
that guy sells stupid that's where we
went to go see Dave Chappelle came and
we went to go see him I texted Donnell
and we went to go see his show did you
see uh Ed Sheeran
am I saying that right why are you
laughing Sharon I just don't picture you
don't you think I would miss an Ed
Sheeran show yeah but like he was here
with Snoop Dogg in Melbourne like Snoop
was here with him Snoop Ed Sheeran no no
dude no no no no they were in a photo
together in Melbourne and it seems like
every [__] celebrity is staying at
this hotel well no that's he's he's he's
he was alone he was solo but people from
the crew went to go see Ed Sheeran and
then and then the other young guy that's
the other young Styles Harry Styles was
here yeah yeah they're all in a photo
together yeah well they're all they're
all [__] partying that John kanary
that block of like sports arena all that
stuff every show happens there if it's
of that size there's nowhere else they
play in Melbourne besides that that
little chunk block Chrysler is going to
go there wow where's your show tonight
what's it called the the plenary plenary
plenary the plenary p-l-e-n-a-r-y
plenary yeah plenary right it's crazy
yeah it's it's over double what my
previous biggest show of my life was so
sick that's so sick yeah you got to move
down here you can become arj Barker you
know you know Arch Barker no you guys
don't know that guy archbarker is a
great comic that was on Flight of the
Concords he was like the only non
kiwi that was on Flight of the Concords
if you ever saw that show and he was you
know I think he loved it down down here
so much he moved I think he lives in New
Zealand full-time now he was an American
comic that did great but down here he's
a God yeah I think I can live down here
like Hasselhoff in Germany 100 dude that
guy why leave yeah I could live here
I've said this multiple times this city
I could live I could 100 live here yeah
um
you could but but you wouldn't no you're
on fire right now I could but I won't
let let's get right down to it here yeah
you are hot right now sexy right now
hotter than it's going away they're red
hot redder than my hair yeah my face
yeah my boss it's uh it's it's awesome
man and um you're you're special
cheeseburger cheeseburger I I had to
text you after I watched the whole thing
I love when I watched somebody's project
all the way through the end yeah take a
photo of the credits credit roll yes
proof receipt that I watched all the way
through I respect that and I I I really
really thoroughly enjoyed it thank you
dude the the suggestion that if anybody
uh should ever find that they have
inserted a little vibrator into their
bottom and cannot get it out that the
only rational thing to do is to kill you
kill yourself yeah and then the little
act out of your walking
yeah the vibrator on your tush dude it's
a scary moment in time when you get
stuff stuck in your cavity my buddy used
to tell me stories all the time people
would come in with crazy [__] people put
that was a that's a tame story because I
didn't want to gross people out but he
was like my buddy that works in the
yards like the amount of people that put
crazy stuff in their butt and it's it's
awful because it rips them to it like
can kill you it rips your insides no
doubt you gotta be careful what you put
in your body and that is why I'm so
happy to tell you guys about Bluetooth
because I love putting it in my body it
is a delicious chewable tablet that has
the same active ingredient as both
Viagra and Cialis except it only costs a
fraction of the price and when I put it
in my body man wonderful things happen I
think you know what I'm talking about
and it is very good for my love life
plus you can get an entire month's
supply of Bluetooth tablets absolutely
for free and only pay five dollars for
shipping if you go to
bluetooth.com and use the promo code
Stevo that's right plus it's ever so
easy when you consult with one of their
online medical providers at
bluetooth.com to take care of the
prescription and get that entire month's
Supply on its way to you completely for
free you only pay five dollars for
shipping and once again that is at
bluechew.com with the promo code Stevo
now let's get back to it there there's a
emting there's a person that like put a
bottle of wine up his butt broke and he
couldn't get it out and so he was like
trying to smash it against the wall to
like and it cut his whole butthole up
and so like at sex shops they make uh
bottles of wines with holes cut in the
bottom for the air circulation to go
through because people are going to do
it anyway so you might as well have a
hole in the bottom so you can get it out
it's not like
um that's a very that's very that's
let's see this is sextiles are getting
they're getting here they're
sophisticated dude how come but how this
how come I asked this the other day
dildos always have balls they always
have balls dildos always have balls on
them do they always gonna never have
balls on them no I've seen dildos with
balls push back okay but vibrators don't
have balls no why not
because don't you want vibrating balls
yes that's what the [__] Ring's for no
no but if you're using a vibrator
wouldn't it be nice to also have a pair
of little little balls that roam around
this podcast got age restricted a while
back yeah yeah yeah edit all that out
dude edit that out you know what you're
doing right get yourself another iced
latte and cut cut cut cut
sitting in a cool dark room so the um
the I I noticed that you said because
because we we had like kind of scheduled
in time to do the podcast and then you
were like oh sorry bud gotta pull out
again I just booked a a movie in
Australia this was it that was like
right after the special came out and I
thought oh that special was so good no
he's got the job offers flowing in no no
not true no no I mean it's that this
this came on a weird I told you the
roundabout story of this before we
started rolling but like this kind of
was on an accident but I was I you know
this I mean you can tell that yeah that
you had read the script yeah I read the
script I read the script for Ricky's
Nicky like almost a decade ago and I
talked to the directors Pete Farrelly
The Fairly Brothers people that know it
did Dumb and Dumber and something about
Mary and Shallow Hal and every one of
your favorite movies if you're in around
your 40s
um and Pete had this script and then it
got sent around I read it and I had a
meeting with him begged him to be in it
I did I said I would do it for free I
would do anything it took and that was
years ago and then time passed and they
couldn't make it I got traded to Studio
it got Rewritten like six seven times
and then cut to more recently I ran into
Pete again with Larry David at a charity
event and Pete was like we're gonna make
that movie and I was like are you
serious he's like we're making that
movie and and Larry David vouched tree
LD was very the politeness of LD was
huge because he didn't have to say [__]
he was kind of on his way through he
could have just been like oh hey but he
was you know he kind of hyped me up a
little bit and having the Larry David
vouchers like yeah what else is there
really and uh Then Pete was like trying
to work it out and it wasn't going to
work for other reasons we weren't gonna
be able to do it and I got back from
Paris with Stavros and uh Theo and
Andrew Schultz which we never belonged
in Paris in the first place they paid us
to go to Paris to make jokes at a
fashion show it was it was the dumbest
it was bound to fail but it worked and
it looked great on social dude it was it
was rad and uh what's her name uh
Cindy Crawford holy [__] what I'm crazy
I can't think of her name this is like
drawing such a bad blank uh it was
hosted by um uh dude the most famous
runway model of all time what's her name
Tyra Bank Tyra Banks yeah I don't know
why I couldn't do that I'm like losing
my mind she um she was so rad and so
nice and I thought she wasn't gonna be a
want to be around a bunch of annoying
comedians she was kicking it the whole
time like you would assume she'd be like
I don't want to hang around these
[__] but she sat with us joked with
us laughed like it was Super Rad and
then afterwards I was like we're gonna
go out and have something to eat
and her partner was with her and she was
like we're gonna go we're gonna go
somewhere else and I was like did I bet
you they're going to the most like bomb
ass place in Paris like the most dope
like underground secretive sexy place we
met back up with her in the lobby later
that night she's like we're gonna jump
on a plane and we're leaving soon I was
like okay well it's good to see you good
to meet you I was like where'd you guys
end up going to eat and I'm like bracing
for something amazing she's like we went
to Five Guys
I was like really she's like yeah
they've got this bomb ass bacon shake
and I was like that's so rad after a
fashion show she went to Five Guys yeah
how was it working on curb what was it
great probably this probably the second
or third greatest moment of my life in
comedy did you have a script or was it
improv does everybody know curb and you
don't have to say Curb Your Enthusiasm
yeah I think everywhere everyone
everyone in our world knows for sure but
curb was you know auditioning it was so
fun because I was supposed to go in for
this role for uh uh there's if you've
seen the episode the last season was
there's a guy with a dog named Adolf
yeah do you remember that episode where
he's like why would you name it Adolf
he's like it's a family name and and
Larry but so they wanted me to do that
so I went in there with like a German
accent
and it crushed and then Larry told
Allison who casts the show who put me in
the office she put me in a bunch of
stuff
she was like he he was like he he
doesn't look Aryan Duty as red hair like
this is when we want a guy that looks
like a Hitler boy you know like this guy
isn't gonna that's not gonna work
so I was a little bummed because they
talked about it like right in the room
and then Larry was like I want but I
want him in some I want him to do
something so they they had this other
character they were building the latte
Larry's uh which is the competition for
you know if you've seen the show you
should watch the show but and they said
they want this like construction worker
to help construct this like perfect
urinal for Larry and so Allison gave me
the character description and then sent
me in the hallway and she's like We're
going to take some other auditions for
the Hitler dog guy but you know do you
want to come back later today and I said
no just give me like three minutes to
read this and I'll come back so one guy
read
I you know came back in the room and
Larry was like what are you doing here
and I was like I'm ready and she was
like you don't want any more time I was
like no I'm good and then I improv with
Larry and I made him break like three
times and he was like get the [__] out
of here and then I knew I just knew when
I got in the car I knew because he kept
laughing in the middle of the thing and
then was like just get get out of here
and when he kicked me out I knew I was
like all right we're good yeah it was
Rad but I did some of the beats that I
did in the show like one of the things I
did on that I actually duplicated that I
improved in the room that I took to the
show was
JB's move
saw it was me and was like oh so oh
what's up sir and then immediately was
like I'm gonna get in the scene and he
just like got in the scene because we
were you know doing jokes about having
your dick near the urinal and the one
joke that landed in the room that I did
was he was like how how was this wall
gonna know and I was like we'll have a
dick detector immediately when you walk
up to it it'll detect your penis size
stature it'll know how far you need to
be from the toilet and the door will
slide up and it'll go dude penis
detected and Larry broke in the middle
of the room started dying laughing and
he's like dude do the do the noise thing
again do it again and so I was doing all
these different robot sounds for the
pisser and he I knew on the day he was
like bring all that [__] to the thing so
we did you know
I don't know
20 minutes of takes and then that was my
day I mean it was lightning fast it was
just like go go go go go go go go and
then you're done you're it's super quick
because they improv they improv one big
scene Larry goes no to that yes yes no
yes no and then you do it again and then
he goes yes to that no bring that other
thing back and then one more and by that
the third take you really are like
whittling it down to almost it's like
writing a good joke it's like you
Whittle it right down to it trim all the
fat yeah and he broke a few times which
was huge like it was nice to make him
laugh but I was diligently working on
not laughing at JB because maybe one of
the funniest people I've ever seen live
in my entire life like he just is so
good at that character on that show and
making up just chaotic nonsense you know
like he was talking about how like what
side of what side of the pants that your
your penis is on dictates what kind of
man you are anyone on a whole rant about
that and I was it was just so funny it
never even made it into the cut but from
that Larry took a piece of that to do
something house and that's how they work
like they're little comedy magicians he
like takes a thing moves the thing puts
it here there but he see I think he
knows every single beat he really wants
to end up at but he lets you find it a
little bit on your own that's crazy he
said he's the greatest comedic producer
performer I've ever worked with live in
my life by far did Bobby have that same
experience because I because I didn't
realize Bobby was the Korean bookie on
like season three yeah yeah and I mean
was he said Bobby was having a panic
attack the entire time and yeah knowing
what to do but he did he did good though
no he did great he but he'll tell you he
did terrible like he'll he'll he'll
probably complain about it you know and
be like Oh Larry didn't like me and you
know he's a psycho dude he's the
craziest piece of [__] I've ever known
and I hate his guts more than anything
and he's my best friend and I hate him
and you guys have shows coming up it's
shy Bobby yeah we have 35 cities go to
badfriendspod.com
Steve's been on the show and that show
was so crazy when you came on you guys
showed me your butthole and it was
amazing it was [__] rad dude you
asked for it both buttons both of them
they both have beautiful buttholes
beautiful butts clean clean clean clean
pipe yeah keep it clean how did that
episode perform killed what do you mean
it did phenomenal the fans loved that
[__] we went in because you went off in
these tangents and these wild worlds you
were on one dude you were like because
you had been editing for like a full day
straight and so you were when you came
in you were like all right dude we gotta
[__] do this man
it's like you were looking off into the
Horizon the whole time but we let you
fly and it was super fun and but me and
him are taking the show on the road
we're doing like
kind of an interactive showcase we're
not doing a sit-down pod we do both do
stand up we have jet ski Johnson Jesse
Johnson opened the show who's so rad
we're gonna have other guest star
comedians on the road in different
cities that we're at and then we're
going to do a bunch of bits from the
show pre-recorded videos that you guys
can see sketches and then bits that
involve the audience a ton of stuff that
involves the audience it's more like a
give back of like be a part of this show
that you've been supporting for four
years now look at what we've all made
together type of thing how many cities
33 right now I think I think it's going
to get up to maybe 40 when it's done
because the fans are it's so funny dude
you post dates and you're like hey look
at all these places I'm going to be like
why aren't you coming here man yeah and
you're like sorry man sorry we're
figuring it out like this isn't you know
we didn't avoid you on purpose but
here's the thing I I've been on my
bucket list tour for a long time oh yeah
and so I'm always posting new dates and
when I post new dates every one of those
comments is about a place I've already
been you already went yeah it's so
annoying man that's so annoying that
when are you coming to Baltimore it's
like we left Baltimore yesterday yeah
that happens all the time dude it's but
also when somebody goes huge fan this is
my biggest pet pee huge fan what are you
doing in town I'm like how big of a fan
can you be if you don't know why I'm
here today or Steve's is uh dude I'm
such a huge fan can I buy you a drink
it's like he's been sober 15 years yeah
no no oh yeah by the way is that now it
is
right now dude congrats Dad thank you
that is so cool I read it online this
morning and I thought I wonder if this
was an Old Post I didn't look at the
date but I was like oh [__] is this one
of those you know where Instagram gives
you something that was like six days ago
and then you're like what what how did
that get in there yesterday that my
birthday came early because we're 19
hours ahead yeah that's right that's
right I forgot so now Australia time it
was yesterday but La time it's now uh
March 9th Yeah March 10th yeah 10th I
mean yeah March 10th yeah that was
convoluted do you feel 15.
um I I mean I I I'm profoundly grateful
for my sobriety and
I'm also really grateful that we finally
are doing this me too dude yeah and it's
on this see this means a lot because
sobriety you change you grow you learn
yeah and this is what we did you eat
[__] some days you eat [__] right
um so so uh the Netflix special yes like
um
it's no secret that Netflix has
experienced some turbulence yeah but uh
but they've also got hellacious bangers
coming out left and right yeah they're
still putting it together I I think
they're doing a little bit they've
censored that the Chris Rock special
which I thought was really did you see
this I I didn't I saw clips of it they
censored it well apparently they pulled
out the Will Smith thing or something
wait what no that's the only reason why
anybody watched it I know it's not true
though didn't they do this
I saw it like clips of it from Netflix
I just read an article that said
something this morning uh that said that
they're gonna remove it maybe or
something I could be wrong I highly
doubt that no but I think it would Chris
not Netflix
you know what I'm saying look at let me
see let's see I you just have to cut
this out I doubt that Chris Rock removes
Will Smith joke from special
oh wow can they do that after the fact
on Netflix I mean sure they can do
whatever they want on Netflix but Chris
Rock's fumbled Will Smith choke removed
from Netflix special it's every article
I can Chris Rock's Netflix show the Will
Smith's joke will be removed LA Times
all this fumbled Will Smith joke
um if you watch the original he does
stumble he [__] up the joke if you
watch the original he
I don't know what he said he's he he uh
concussion when he gets to the word
concussion he like tells a piece of it
incorrectly and he talks about saying it
wrong he's like I [__] that up but
then he continues on
um but it's only one line it's a little
sliver yeah it's a little tiny sliver of
a thing that okay so because they're not
pulling out the no no no no no no no but
they're removing the piece which is
strange because it's like why'd you put
it in the first place you had Final Cut
you I watched mine a thousand times yeah
I watched it so many times you hate
every single SEC you hate the way your
stupid face looks you know you're like
look at my teeth you know like you start
to like pick yourself to shreds you're
like way to go you fat dad like
everything looks sad when you keep
watching it so I there's no way he
didn't see that a hundred times and
think about it which is weird that he
put it out because it's like well it was
live where did he film it at a comedy
store no no he filmed it at uh Baltimore
yeah Maryland yeah
um it's a weird idea though to because
he could have easily cut that out
yeah I mean like he could have easily it
was streamed live as it happened so it
would be an after the future there's
always a delay on those when they do
those those streams are never live left
you know what I mean okay never they
can't do that they know better right
yeah they're smart after all these years
of all that stuff that they're like now
they're like there's always a delay so
they could have pieced something
together I just think that like
I think Chris as as
in my opinion the greatest comedic
writer of Our Generation he works man I
think he's I think he was still nervous
about saying that joke because it hurt
him so much I think that thing hurt him
so much you think it hurt his career no
some things hurt and some things don't
you know what hurt me or at least used
to overspending on shaving products man
with the gimmicky razors that light up
or vibrate all this nonsense that nobody
needs and then I started using Harry's
Harry's gives you exactly what you need
nothing more it's classy it's got these
quality five blade razors and you can
get a hairy starter kit with everything
that you need and all you're going to
spend is three bucks man this is a 13
value the five blade razor the weighted
ergonomic handle the foaming shave gel
and the travel cover it's a 13 value
you're gonna get it for just three
dollars and free shipping it's crazy how
good this deal is if you're sick and
tired of wasting money on stuff you
don't need then man join the Harry's
movement like I did years ago go to
harrys.com slash Devo for this epic deal
and do it right now harrys.com
Stevo now let's get back to it
no I think no I think it hurt him as a
as a human as a friend as a fan as a
homie because they have a relationship
and it's like
dude each year is one thing but hitting
me in the face in front of [__] 30
million people is like 30 million come
on
well I mean I don't even know how many
people saw that but how many songs live
I don't know I'm saying live whatever it
is forget about live yeah but within the
next 48 hours but if you hit in the face
in front of in front a lot like that I
mean yeah that would that would do
something to you for the rest of time in
the ultimate Heckle yeah 100 like
imagine somebody heckling you but then
like it's the biggest yeah well on the
live stage it's the ultimate Heckle it's
like it's like you can't get more and
well but also it's a salt at the other
day it's like don't you can't mean the
[__] face you should have kept his
wife's name out of his [__] mouth
oh
so funny so weird so obviously damaged
to do that so scary and sad I have
buddies with Eric Andre yeah who was
with Chris Rock on tour for a while
there I believe while he was putting
together his tambourine special and uh
Apparently after every show
um Chris Rock had the show recorded yeah
and then got in the private jet sent
the recording to a transcriber who typed
it up into a script sent it back and he
read through the script and like you
know marked it up and yeah it's genius
like every single time yeah my the great
writers know how to do that to a way
that they are the meticulousness of it
that would if I watch it over and over
I'd get it would give me anxiety
like I can listen to it but reading it
and watching it is tough for me
listening to it's okay because I can
kind of hear my rhythm better and feel
it my
one of my wife's old older old friends
her
she was a uh I don't know how to say it
assistant or whatever or like a family
helper for Carl for the carlands and uh
for kotlin's wife and would say that
George would um meticulously write out
all his stuff like in his room I don't
know if he's on a whiteboard or a wall
or paper
and he would write it out and he'd
recite it almost like it was you know
like his script he's memorizing for his
[__] bar mitzvah and he would do it
for hours and hours and hours and hours
and hours and hours you would hear him
just like repetitively go the same
phrase like a thousand times until he
got the rhythm of the phrase that he
liked the most but that's the level of
chaos that some of those guys have to
that because their rhythm is so
important
I I wish I could learn that but it gives
me anxiety like thinking about reading
my words over and over vibrator in the
butt over and over and over yeah I mean
that when Steve would have me open from
like I would write it out listen to it
and reread it because I hate public
speaking and I would black out up there
so I would read it probably 200 times
you would do it yeah yeah it was more of
like a cruel prank I was like hey you're
opening so I would go up for like a 1500
people and I never done stand up before
and I'd be like yeah I can't do that
[__] I mean
171. it's been a long time but but the
thing was do it now in front of 5000
tonight yeah [__] up dude [__] no come
on dude get up there be a man we used to
have
um like uh you know comedy clubs just
sort of assign a local comic to be the
opener right and it just never had
anything to do with it just felt like
disjointed and and I remember that when
I had started the bucket list tour my
show started running longer because it's
multimedia I have like video breaks and
stuff to like pay off stories and um you
know and then I was going a little
longer I was like I definitely don't
need two openers and and man like why
let this money go to some random it was
like Scott you up and take the money and
keep it all like uh kind of in the
ecosystem so that uh you know and the
the fact that that we met in um
like uh this sort of recovery scenario
for sex addiction is Juicy and fun yeah
it's very fun very juicy very fun are
you Sober Sober yeah all of it too yeah
yep you don't do like the California
sober thing he just turned 10. I'm 15
today and he he's 10 years sober as of
nine days ago yeah what was that what
was one my buddy who's a friend who's
working on the film is sober and uh
he's been sober for 20 years and I was
like what's your what's your you know
I mean my drug of choice would be
drinking a lot yeah cocaine and then
towards the end I would like pile a lot
of cocaine in my what's your what's your
now what's your replacement what's your
now post sober what's your little thing
your little naughty boy thing food is
specific though
his is chocolate so we will go out and
he has to have chocolate and he's like
sad about it because he'll eat so much
chocolate my thing is not like sugar
sweets like I'll eat that a little bit
carbs pasta but it's like eating enough
for two people so like I'll order like
70 worth of sushi and eat the whole
thing when like you see other people eat
sushi and they're just like eat like a
six like I'll just take one roll yeah
and I'm just like that's appetizer dude
yeah yeah I get it I get that but do you
exercise I used to okay well then I
started eating if you want to eat for
two exercise for two you know what I
mean yeah but you can do it yeah well I
turned 40 next month and so like in my
head I'm like okay I'm just gonna kind
of like act out until I turn 40 and then
I'm gonna make it all about like my
health
dude that logic is so [__] that's so
funny oh yeah for sure
that's like and then I'll go to the
doctor I'll do like I get married to my
wife I'll stop [__] dudes okay I'll
stop that'll make me straight again I
know it's [__] up I have like a weird
logic but like that's my I'll go to the
doctor you know my blood pressure's
already high so like maybe I'll start
there cut out salts and we're the same
age I didn't know we were the same age
39 same dude I'll be 40 this year as
well are you doing anything for 40.
yeah I'll be in Australia on the next
Encore tour yeah this Australian tour is
gone huge dude I watched all your dates
online I was like holy [__] and it's
like another month yeah come back for a
whole other month and thank you by the
way you're nuts dude I know I'm really I
really honestly you're absurd I don't
know anybody has your work ethic it's
repulsive it's like I feel like I'm
drowning in work and then I see your
tours and I'm like you're [__] off
your head dude in a good way because you
care I will say this dude you're you
know I've seen what you do over the
years and I've only in this last couple
of years like really gotten to know you
and see you like for real and
your work ethic is [__] huge you give
a [__] it's good what you put together
is like it's just solid I think you've
understood more than ever now what
you're doing you know which is obvious
and uh you know it's not a kiss-ass
party but you should be super proud
because it's like it's yeah it's good
that you figured out exactly how to how
to deliver you in the best way and you
did 100 because it's true man the show
it's [__] great you're so you're so
who you are it's unmistakable you know
like when a comic finds their voice
whatever that annoying phrase is do you
know what I mean but it's real but it is
a real thing when someone finds the
thing that that they do the best it's so
obvious it's like oh yeah what the [__]
what what were you doing before you know
when you were when you're searching
you're fishing fishing fishing and then
sometimes you have to step back and be
like what I would this is what I was the
best at why was I even trying other
things it's like that's the best version
but it's great and you're never gonna
stop during now you're just gonna
[__] you're gonna die on the road
it's like George Carlin you are you're
just like him very much man honestly and
you're in a and you're in a bus
um sort of I saw I saw it leaking yeah
well which grossed me out hard I was
like [__] dude I'm a germaphobe that
would I'd be panic mode I'm sure that
the the leak holes are all perfectly
plugged and then everything's it's all
packed I mean the the where that bus
came from it is just Rock Solid
professionals yeah we uh we found the
only tour bus in Australia so that's
where that came from isn't that funny
because this feels like uh it's no
offense to them because I've said this I
love Melbourne I 100 could I mean it
when I say I could move I love this I've
fallen in love with this place
they're behind the times on the things
that we need when you come here you're
like oh wow they don't really have a lot
of access to the same things that we
take for granted I absolutely
think that Scott and I should open up a
tour bus company yeah in Australia I
think that the the need for that is so
glaring or some or even multimedia
company here there's not a ton of them
right like I found stupid old Studios
shout out to stupid old Studios I shot
uh my two podcasts there it's I found a
great studio in town a friend
recommended it and uh so rad and they're
one of the only ones that has like a
full Stage Studio it's a little too
elaborate for podcasts but it's it
worked it was what I needed and hardcore
shout out to them and I was like are you
guys the only game in town and they're
like well there was like one other one
but there's not enough of multimedia
like this here so they're finding out
it's like slowly growing again dude it's
like it's like hip-hop in Japan you're
like oh this is 10 years ago yeah it's
almost there it's like it's catching up
is there anything in Australia that
they're doing that they're doing better
than the America right now because I
find that like paying with the the tap
and pay if people are just using their
watches people are tapping it like it's
so efficient who doesn't love efficiency
and who doesn't love a good deal man the
deals are getting better from our
sponsors
mattresses from Helix that's Helix
sleep.com Stevo like now up to
350 off your brand new mattress and you
want to talk about efficiency when you
go to Helix sleep.com slash Stevo it
doesn't take two minutes to fill out
their quiz to figure out what's actually
the perfect mattress for you man I'm so
glad that for like three full years now
I have had my Helix mattresses working
for me so well dude and you need a new
mattress I know it so get up to 350 off
of any mattress and two free pillows if
you go to Helix sleep.com slash Stevo I
just so grateful for our sponsors being
so wonderful to our listeners so jump on
that deal and let's get back to it no
that's that's the by the way that's the
whole world you know that we're the only
country that's behind the really you're
up dude everyone Taps there's no such
thing also bring the machine to the
table great yeah don't take my credit
card to the back bring it right to my
face tap it let's leave I like it the
efficiency level is so high it's crazy I
think they do so many more things better
than us also uh metric system [__]
and guns they're not killing everybody
every five seconds yeah you know you
know uh 12 of the entire country is has
a registered gun 12 in America it's like
000 guns are are registered it's three
times their register and the ones that
aren't registered is like seven times
that
Street guns they don't have street
street guns don't exist have you ever
watched the news here it's comical
they're like today drama unfolded as a
you know a big banger in a parking lot
turned out to be fireworks dude it's
it's the most tame nothing happens [__]
and it's so good it's like the
healthiest version of boring boring life
you're like it's great no one gets
killed for no reason kids aren't getting
shot that's the one thing you know not
to be on my little [__] liberal [__]
kick but like
dude the no the no crazy gun accidents
is like why the [__] can we not figure
that [__] out yeah well I mean I think
they're actually relatively few gun
accidents in America well no in the
stage dude the highest the highest the
highest
or John Stuart children the highest
killer of children in the United States
is bigger than cancer uh it's bigger
than
um uh uh auto accidents yeah car
accidents it's it's guns accidental gun
deaths is number one for children dying
in America accidental huh yeah because
dude kids shoot themselves with their
parents gonna go look at my dad's gun
they're [__] around or or they're in
the neighborhood and some kid has a gun
and they're goofing around and they're
[__] off and it's not deliberate the
highest amount of child deaths I'm not
trying to get on a kick but it's like
those when Jon Stewart said that like
the facts are so glaring it's like what
Josh Jones pretty great that whole thing
the guy's the jeep with the dumbass
Republican guy that guy was so stumped
he's like these drag queens need to cut
it out oh they're like the Mississippi
Governor or whatever it was it was
pretty amazing that that guy agreed to
be interviewed by Jon Stewart you know
those guys think we talked about that on
set the other day I think those guys
think that they're gonna have a leg up
like they're like dude I'm prepared I
came with all my notes this guy's not
gonna get me I'm not a I'm not some dip
[__] like the other people who
interviews and then they get there and
he's stone-faced cannot believe he's
trapped once again it's like you can't
Stewart's going to beat you I would
never he's gonna beat you why yes the no
gun thing is kind of chill shocked that
12 of Australia has registered guns no
12 12 of of the country's population 12
is a legally registered gun for hunting
activities right so they register the
gun but uh that's nothing in comparison
I mean it's true it's wild that's that
that I I would have lost a big bet yeah
if we chose well keep your guns Love
Your Guns America do whatever you want
to do it's kind of nice to not hear like
[__] I'm from Chicago so like when I
read the Tribune every day it's like the
most depressing thing on earth you're
like how many more kids are killed for
no reason only 25 a day it's still
particular it's disgusting yeah it's
true
um why are you so you live in L.A and
you're moving to New York are you going
to keep your place in L.A I'm gonna keep
my spot in La I'm just gonna go back and
forth a little bit wow Bobby keeps
fighting and he's like you can't go you
can't go that's so funny like I'm gonna
keep my spot in L.A like I wonder like
if you spend uh six months in a day in
New York is that more expensive for
taxes than six months a day here L.A New
York is you're not getting out of taxes
you'd have to move to Nevada or Texas or
Tennessee or Washington or I've looked
it up Florida yeah no dude going to New
York is not for money I'm not saving
money if I wanted to leave and save
money I'd get out of California
completely because it's a [__] but
I'm going to New York because I love New
York and I'm sick of not being there I
have so much fun when I'm back East I'm
from Chicago I like the East so much
stronger
La is also you know not to dump on it
but it's burnt I burnt out I've been
there it's pretty gnarly a burnt out
dude I've been there since 06 and I'm
It's Time to Say Goodbye for a little
bit I just I just want something new
I'll tell you exactly why truly when I
sit with my dad and his friends and I
talk to these guys the old heads and
I'll hear these great stories about some
of his friends like I moved to Memphis
for a woman then I took a job in
Virginia then I moved to Jersey and then
I was in Ohio for this thing and then
they tell these like great elaborate
Beautiful Stories and look that's not
our life our life is more nomadic and
strange but for some reason we always
end up at the same place we're back in
La I'm back in La I'm back in LA and I
was like why can't I just go somewhere
else for a little while and have that be
a new chapter in my life so because I'm
turning 40 I was like by 40 I want to
have a new chapter
so I think this is just an excuse to
like have a new chapter and feel
something new the comedy scene in New
York is one of my [__] favorites the
the seller treats me so well I get to go
there and do whatever I want and so I
just want something new I just I want to
I Wanna daddy wants a new pair of shoes
midlife crisis we're turning 40 dude no
you know what I call it midlife
assessment I think it's an assessment
it's not a crisis you're just assessing
what you need and what you want you're
looking at your life and going I don't
need this anymore I don't like this
thing I'm not doing that [__] that I do
like this I will start doing this more
like I saw this guy that sends gratitude
texts
he was like every morning I sent three
gratitude texts and I'm trying more and
more every day to reach out to people a
couple people a day and just be like hey
man just thinking of you because I am
because for you just you know you don't
you don't say hi to people as much
anymore you get too busy yeah you don't
focus on any of that [__] so and I think
I'm trying all the time like uh like uh
dude it would be good to just reach out
to that person and just send them some
love I have that thought and then the
thought goes away and I'm on a gratitude
thread and it comes up in the morning
I'm just like [__] dude I gotta [__]
respond to these people it's like I love
the guys
but I think the more you do it the more
you realize like uh I think I think it
also takes getting out of your own thing
like coming here changed my mind about a
lot of stuff or like refocusing what I
like and what I don't like I started to
really think about a lot of stuff like
that
uh do I miss Bobby yeah no no still
don't miss Bob I don't give a [__] about
that guy
no I love him I text him all the time he
doesn't you know he's a [__] he's a
piece of [__] I do believe that I I just
for no reason whatsoever sent Bobby uh
like hey man I love you what do you say
back says I love you too that's nice
that he responded yeah he said I love
you too I'll send you a message like
love you dude and Steve just thumbs UPS
it
yeah no but I I miss um I I miss like my
old old friends so I talk to them as
more than I ever have like like the
three homies that I'm grew up with well
those guys I
talk all the time they're not in the
business they're just old buddies and
are those your golfing buddies you I see
you on Instagram sometimes no those are
guys from back home back in Chicago yeah
these are just like guys I grew up with
my buddy James that I you know we'll
just call each other to talk like you
know like two little high school girls
and we'll chat for like an hour and a
half about life and
finances and family and love and
[__] and we'll just chat and chat
and chat those are like my favorite
things dude homies from back in the day
what what do you think the difference in
your career has been because you're kind
of blowing up on movies and [__] like it
was there like can you trace it back to
a like a set of like a a mindset where
you're like [__] it like I think I think
uh I can't point it to one thing I don't
know how these magic words
I think I think if I could point it back
to one thing if I'm being genuine if I
really dissected it
um it was it was doing my own thing with
the pods and doing [__] online because I
you know I was like TV and film I wasn't
hot enough or famous enough to get in
movies and I was like okay I'll just be
as funny as I can in my own little space
and they'll either come along for the
ride or I'll just make a living doing it
my own thing and as simple as it sounds
but it did work I mean I've been doing
whiskey ginger for six years now I don't
even know and I did it because Rogan
bullied me into it he was like you're
really good at potting you should just
make up your own show and I didn't want
to do it and then he was like you want
to make your own audience or you want to
[__] sit and wait for this stupid
machine you like to create it for you so
he was right I mean he's also anti-tv
and film which he's wrong I mean I loved
even I love doing I love acting and
stuff I've I want to make something dope
uh so I'll never stop that but I
genuinely believe it was doing the Pod
and then me getting together with Bobby
like reinvigorated a part of our careers
that wasn't there before and then people
see it and they're like whoa what the
[__]
these guys are you know you guys have a
solid fan base huge yeah it's wonderful
I'm dude I'm so appreciative of what we
created together we created a little
nugget of psychopaths that love to watch
us fight we we really truly made that
because
I said it before that show was birthed
from his relapse when his dad died and
he relapsed he pulled me aside in the
hallway at his old condo
and I knew something was wrong
and he was like told then he told me
that he was high and I knew I knew
something was weird and he was like if
you tell anybody I will never talk again
and so immediately I went home and I
panicked told everybody yeah what am I
going to do I was like I have to start
telling people I can't I can't hide this
is nuts
but I didn't tell kalila and at the time
they were together
and uh you know she had reached out to
me far after the fact that this all went
away
and was like I'm really sorry he put you
in that predicament I understand why you
didn't come to me because it was like
what am I gonna
get in the middle of their relationship
like it was it was really a vulnerable
position for me to be in so I made it my
own way to get him to try to get help
without having to bring it to the
relationship part because it was really
hard man yeah how long ago was that
because we talked about it on the last
time he was on the podcast like my
brother was on tour with him and he
ratted them out yeah and uh he still
hasn't talked to my brother since then
yeah well he's a vindictive [__] I
mean he's a [__] [__] but but
also you know sobriety and addiction
makes you do [__] really strange
things to people that you love so I
think he's always going through it but
that was in 20
he's telling the truth like he'll never
talk to you again if you [__] tell
any 100 well and I knew when his dad
died he was avoiding the idea that his
dad was dead it was like he faked it he
like showed up
he he it's like he didn't care and I was
like this is fake it's you care so
you're dealing with it in a way that you
don't want to communicate and obviously
it was using behind everybody's back so
once that came to
that came to the surface
I knew everything was going to kind of
collapse so he went away to rehab and
then when we went to Mexico where I saw
you guys he relapsed again and then
that was that was
that was kind of like a um a window into
the world of what it's like to like have
one of your best friends really really
struggle with addiction because I you
know of that addicts in my life my dad
really good friends but I didn't never
seen it like I did with Bobby where
he'll he'll he'll he'll put you in a
really vulnerable position like really
vulnerable dude it was crazy threatened
you know he threatens you and does all
this [__] manipulative [__] to
make you be like yeah well they're out
of their [__] mind but like you don't
really believe it because you're like
dude it's Bobby but like he's really
just no different than any other [__]
psycho alcoholic that's like saying some
weird [__] yeah he just didn't he just
never he you know but now he's got such
a good grasp that I'm like happy for him
that he's functioning again
clear-headed and he's found a new level
from this second term of sobriety but
the show was birthed truly because we
joked about doing a show I filled in for
him when he was having some trouble me
and Kyla would do tigerbelly together
and then
we had joked about doing the show and
then when he relapsed he pulled me aside
when kalila called him out and they sent
him away to rehab and he's like I had a
realization that like we we should
become
closer instead of this Fringe thing that
we're doing and actually do the show
together and commit and you know and you
guys don't have guests on you guys
basically sometimes we have guests on
that we know are fun for the show yeah
we usually don't want people on the show
but like Steve and there's guys that
like we know are
fun as [__] that are going to be fun
with us on the show yeah you know so
like like the fact that you can do it
without a guest is so important yeah
it's because the dynamic is me and that
[__] weirdo is really what it is I
mean we throw in fun people because we
like there's personalities that we just
know that are great with us yeah like
Brad Williams he rips every time he's on
the show absolutely [__] rips we put
him in an elf costume for the Christmas
episode it's one of the funniest
episodes we've ever done and there's a
joke that went viral because uh Rudy on
the show the girl on the show his niece
or Clara's niece was like is there a
dating app for little people and we all
start laughing and and Brad's like
that's a good question I was like it is
a good question and I said what's the
name of it and and I was like wait a
minute let us guess let us have a comedy
guess at this and dude Bobby the fastest
I've ever seen him he goes a thumbel and
I I [__] lost my [__]
there's moments like that that you're
like yeah when the dynamic is firing
it's flawless I mean when it's when it's
fun with me and that idiot it's [__]
fun it's the most fun I've ever had it's
more fun than in a TV show I've shot any
movie I've done any stand-ups that I've
ever done when that kid and I are
humming it's the most fun I've ever had
in my entire life
part of the other suggestions for for
the for the little person the lp LP
dating site oh we throw out a million of
them they're on the episode watch the
Christmas episode but I can't we went
for like five minutes making each other
laugh on on [__] but it was just I
don't know like those yeah dude when
we're humming on that show I genuinely
mean it from the bottom of my heart I've
never had more fun as an adult making
comedy it reminds me of when I was 22
and I started and we would talk [__]
after bombing at open mics and we'd all
be in the parking lot making fun of each
other for how bad we bombed it it's the
same thing it felt the same way it was
like innocent and raw and stupid it was
so dumb it's when me and that kid are
talking [__] it's so dumb it's the
dumbest thing on earth it's great how
does that whiskey Ginger compared to
tigerbelly
oh bad friends is huge dude we do a
million downloads a week we're huge that
one's way bigger my shows my show is
like 400 Grand or something like that
it's half of it you know
um it's still a lot though it's a lot
but it's also like uh you know yeah four
to five hundredk but like my show I
liked my show for a totally different
reason that I get to connect with
somebody one-on-one it's quiet it's us
in the room and nobody else which was
birthed out of the pandemic I used to
like have an engineer or have someone
help like these wieners and like or this
wiener specifically and who's not even
looking at us I love the way you do the
fonts different for the guests oh yeah
you like that that's Joe that's my boy
Joe that's Joe Faria does that my my
Boston boy the thumbnails they're great
yeah he he figured out kind of what
works for our our little Vibe is like I
like the Privacy it's you and me that's
it there is no middleman in the room
there's no one else to make you feel a
different way and I sometimes can get
some good vulnerability out I guess
which is what I like you know some guys
don't want to commit but some a lot of
guys will come in with you know when I
was on Whiskey Ginger I got very
vulnerable yeah yeah it's kind of it's
nice to feel it's nice to feel people
like some guys are never gonna do it
when I have [__] like donellon he's
never he's always gonna say
he's going to call me a racist and you
know he's going to make a bunch of like
you're a white piece of [__] Jokes which
is fine I am a white piece of [__] but
like he'll never like get to the other
side piece of [__] yeah piece of [__]
sorry I'm a piece of [__] you white
piece of [__]
but yeah I love but I love the show I
mean I I want to do it until I can't do
it anymore and tiger belly Bobby's right
that uh him and kalilah is Tiger belly
and whiskey Ginger about the same no I
think they do more than us they've been
around for a long time and I don't know
if they're going to continue to do that
show I don't know what all that's what's
going on over there but you know has
there been some drama around tigerbelly
there's some crazy Shia going on over
there no but I think they're still do
they're still doing it they travel to
Hawaii to go to a Hawaiian episode
because Bobby's shooting in Hawaii
Hawaii five or no not Hawaii Five-O
what's going to think of the name of the
show
it's crazy that the the bad friends
um two bears one cave [__] those guys
podcasts that don't require a guest
where you've got a dynamic between two
personalities that just
right the difference between like our
show and two bears is that we're funny
and then
and those guys are fat so it's just a
you know what I mean it's like fat guys
versus funny guys no I love those funny
you guys always win you can't even joke
around about that anymore because Tom is
the like the first of all both those
guys are very funny I'm joking but also
Tom is
the skinniest I've ever seen him dude it
was annoying he really there are some
people that get he's way better looking
well dude he [__] money dude money
and time dude do a lot yeah but he tours
with his like Fitness coach now yeah for
sure why not yeah like if you kind of if
you're Porky your whole life and then
you got money why wouldn't you want to
do what you want to do I mean it's like
kind of like when people are like what'd
that guy get in shape because he wanted
because it's his life and he felt like
getting healthier I like yeah he looks
great people want you to stay
Burt size forever they want bird to stay
Birch size but is that good for Bert I
don't know that's up to him the people
with no Profile Pics want you to stay
shitty but the you know it's just people
with no profile do people with the egg
has the Emoji out of the [__] the
filler
Loser yeah yeah yeah right right okay I
bought dude you're Russian dude you're
Russian no but I think I I think uh the
getting healthy thing that's a [__]
if that's what dude that's good that you
know what that is what Tom did that's
you getting sober it's like that's what
you needed for you to function better in
life and to be the best version of you
as a comic and a friend and a husband
and a buddy and so for him it's like he
feels like he he obviously needs it
because it's not for any other
validation it's for I want to feel
better live longer for my kids yeah
that's great dude get in shape do what
you need to do at 39 Tom was probably
like at 40 I'm gonna start getting
better
yeah yeah look at Dana White I I mean he
uh is like like the 53 yeah remember
that photo of him at the beach with his
shirt off just jacked do you know why it
looks like so much better than he ever
did like
20 years ago yeah like money and time
baby money money and time you gotta have
it dude you gotta have it and you gotta
commit to doing the thing like I've been
working out at a class here and going to
the gym and it's like you have to just
have to like balls up and do it it'd be
easier if I had to trainers are the best
yeah you said that it's been difficult
to be in Australia for a month and a
half because the schedule of America the
time zone difference requires you to get
up at like just some stupid hour in the
morning like you're getting up at like
four in the morning yeah I'll do four or
five a.m if we have like a pitch we're
pitching this show so it's like if I
have to do those you just have to and
you're miserable I mean you're sitting
at the computer exhausted especially if
I shot the day before because we're
doing long shoot days you know like some
of them have been nice and short but
some days are full full days you know
where you're you know you're up at 5am
to take a car to do hair and makeup to
be on set to shoot till 8 P.M you get
home enough time to like shove food in
your face Maybe jerk off and then you're
wake up like you know only a couple
hours later it sucks it's and you're
waking up in the middle of the night to
piss because you're a grown adult male
so it's like at some point your body
gets all freaked out you know and you
have like a crash Sunday or Sunday I
disappear into my bed when do you get
home finally
back in La yeah I go back April and then
we're on the road April 12th so I think
I'm back like the first or second week
of April and then I'm on the road pretty
much right away April 12th is my first
show of my Encore tour of Australia
you'll be down here we start April 12th
as well April 12th is our first show
here no no no no no no we're not coming
here we're gonna try to come here in
another time but April 12th is our first
show
uh Oklahoma City that's so funny where
April 12 is our first show and our last
one is in July or so I have no idea I
feel like uh maybe in Darwin Darwin do
you have any part of you that feels like
I I've got to hurry up and tour a tour
tour before the world just crumbles
around us before the thing blows up yeah
I think not for me but for bad friends I
want a tour bad but for me like just
putting out the special and building
[__] I only have a good an okay chunk of
time now so I'm not in a rush to go tour
for me but for bad friends yeah I want a
tour now bad because well he means when
as long as the opportunity is still high
oh my God I just feel like it's gonna be
there you created an audience they're
gonna be there they're one they want to
see you they love you that's they're
that that that idea that it's like it's
gonna go away that is a that is a
poverty Consciousness yeah that's a
comedics poverty Consciousness that is
something that we injected into our own
psyche and it's stupid it's not healthy
all right it's going to be there your
fans love you they CR you they're not
there tonight because of the timing
they're there because they like you and
they want to see you and it didn't
matter if it was in seven months or ten
months that's something I learned from
the older heads that they're like I'm
bummed that uh but we're both doing
shows I know I would have come back I
would like to come by yourself yeah I
know I want to come see it too that's
what's even more of a bummer because I'm
working out I have a link to it if uh
you know what time do you what time is
your show
yeah I'm doing two two quick little
shows yeah two quickies I'll give you a
link to it man yeah sounds good like the
the it's like exactly one hour on the
the link okay I want to see it yeah
it'll be fun because I I'm working out
like I told them I'm doing new [__] I
said it the poster says new [__] down
under like I'm just working out a ton of
different stuff and uh you know it's
like a fun little tight Comedy Club how
long are you doing
I'll probably do an hour I'll probably
work out for an hour yeah I got I have
like 45 of like [__] new [__] that I
like and then I'll probably do a bunch
of interactive stuff because I've never
been down here so I want to talk to some
of these [__] people because I've
never ever performed down here
um it's rad it's pretty rad the getting
noticed in the streets here is so much
different than in the States because in
the States you know they see you they
know you
here they're like
shot almost mad that you're here yeah
like I've had so many guys be like what
are you doing here mate why are you here
like angry I'm like I'm shooting a movie
and they're like why they're like they
can't they're like mad you're in their
Town yeah but like it's they can't
believe it it's but it's cool I I'm
learning that I should have come here a
long time ago I [__] up like I should
have been here already but we're here
now well you know and I'll come back I
will 100 come back here
and do a run of Australia I don't know
if it's going to be as big as yours how
many cities you do in total in Australia
oh my God 22 then coming back and doing
there's only 22 cities in Australia yeah
yeah well then when you say 22 you're
counting New Zealand but then I think
the next next one is 19. yeah but there
are three of them or four of them are
encore uh same city that's great dude
yeah Jesus Christ yeah it's funny you're
saying that about like people are like
what are you doing here do you remember
yesterday we were riding the bikes and
those two girls were like driving they
pulled over and the one girl pulled over
and she was like she's like dude I'm
[__] crazy in the head like is this
real like is this really happening and
like I believed her that like it's so
crazy to see you there that she honestly
didn't know if that was reality or not
like she had to like talk about that out
loud yeah they're stunned they're like
it doesn't it doesn't make a lot of
sense they kind of can't come they're
like why would you be here in my the
place yeah right well you're also so far
away from home yeah like 7
000 kilometers mate yeah it's only it's
only a 16 hour flight quick little
puddle jumper I think uh how long we've
been going over here
dude
how long have you guys been working
together ah not that long we've got
Jeremy over here for uh
six months eight years
do you like him do we like this guy we
love you guys we love him he directs and
stuff for like uh Discovery
like wow like high level like yeah he
looks like a nerd I like him I like him
a lot high level he's got that cool nerd
like Vibe where he's how many times have
you seen the Northern Lights
yeah
have you ever seen Northern Lights no
man you know what's well no I mean I'll
lie and say yeah but I didn't I was in
Iceland and they said they could see him
and I was like I don't think I can see
him so I guess in Tasmania they have the
Southern Lights right yeah now Northern
Lights it's where the sky flashes these
incredible green colors and it's called
like areola ebolius or
areolais no way why did I just no it's
definitely not Aurora Borealis yeah the
Aurora Borealis yeah Aurora Borealis
areola I'm like you nerd you knew that
like and then apparently like everybody
knows that but dude they do
I've been skunked by the northern lights
in Norway Iceland Alaska like maybe
somewhere else too I'm gonna write a a
diss track
yeah they [__] me every time and then
it's going to be called eat shy
hi
what's that song it's not the Grateful
Dead no
Northern Lights
it's a poem by Robert service not a
Northern Train
is that Casey Jones no it's that I know
you Rider
about Northern Lights
come on dude we got to get it dude
nope yeah with that let me out let me
tell you uh I'm a huge fan of your
comedy ditto dog
if anybody has not seen cheeseburger on
Netflix then and and and uh they did
Netflix tell you it performed great yeah
we got the numbers they do like a 13 day
in the in a 23 day or something I don't
remember
like good quality content is gonna find
an audience and that cheeseburger
special is fantastic thank you dude
genuinely thank you man we did good
despite all the odds of Netflix doing
zero promotion whatsoever which I've
called them out for and they'll admit it
they [__] suck they suck is for they
don't help you do [__] unless you're
Chris Rock they ain't pushing you at all
so I'm glad that we like our fan bases
did it you know because of stuff like
this and our our mutual fan base has
helped grow it organically so millions
of millions of people saw it which is
dope so without that them do they didn't
do [__] [__] Netflix didn't do [__]
no they literally do nothing you didn't
do shy Netflix
they're like it looks great you're like
thanks man what are you what's up and
they're like that's it we're gone yeah
they disappear man it's in the algorithm
baby Netflix is a uh yeah they're
they're like a really bad dad they just
like you know yeah but I made a lot of
money after a stock price last three
months which you do that's huge aren't
they doing bad they went from 700 to
180. they did bad it went it went from
like 700 down to 180 and I bought it at
180 and then it jumped up to like 360.
hell yeah but you got to sell for that
to mean anything never yeah I don't
don't do hold on dude to the Moon right
huddle yeah to the Moon yeah [__] you
still got your board up nfts you got all
your nfts locked up I meant to ask you
yeah people like how many people think
your actual name is Cheeto I mean most
people call me Cheeto yeah like like I
think some people don't know my first
name is Andrew but also nobody calls me
Andrew people say Santino or two though
if I if I hear Andrew something's up
yeah like it's like either a family
member or an assassin you're not if you
haven't seen cheeseburger go on Netflix
cheeseburger please Netflix it is a
fantastic comedy special and that's
coming from a guy who doesn't even
particularly enjoy watching stand up I
love you I appreciate that and also this
is a tip a lot of times look at people
that are in Norway or Sweden or wherever
and they're like
VPN but also this is a trick I learned
from a dude that an Austrian dude online
hit me up if you change your Netflix
settings to American you don't have to
change anything else you just change it
to American you can change it back it
will show you more American programming
so the [__] up thing is when your
Netflix overseas it's catering to your
local you know um your your local IP so
it will it will automatically kind of
that sounds make it harder to find that
sounds helpful but no substitute for no
order VPN yeah VPN is the way to go I
think everyone should be using vpns
anyway but just change your [__]
settings and then you can see it if you
change it to American settings you you
it's I mean there's our English-speaking
countries and they just can't see it I
said Cheetos Santino because that is
your Instagram handle
Cheeto Santino the Cheeto and go watch
cheeseburger Eat A Cheeseburger while
you do it and so many people eat
cheeseburgers while they were watching I
thought that was rad yeah who doesn't
like a cheeseburger I want to see people
comment on your uh last uh Instagram
pick each [__]
I want to see a bunch of each Eyes under
there please yeah shy
and do it twice
I'm writing each eye on a shirt you're
not doing what I'm doing it yeah can we
do it and do like a like a pre a
pre-sale like a uh like why don't we
just print the text why don't we pick
print the text and put put it on a shirt
for both of us this is a little skate
rat over there just did a [__] in Ollie
have you seen the the skate park over
there across the street by the way in
the park you honestly go by there's some
there's a there is a massive half pipe
and I was like Wow most most public
parks don't have half pipes anymore just
for insurance but in America yeah they
have little kickers and you know what I
mean this has a legit huge half pipe and
I was like holy [__] and there was a
couple of dudes on it yesterday we took
our we took our boy Isaac to the
emergency room yesterday for
skateboarding is that your crutches what
do you do what happened
yeah he ain't shy big time and now he's
gonna have to have knee surgery to your
MCL
meniscus
yeah you're done for dude you're [__]
how old are you
he'll be back in a week
anything else we can tell people about
bad friends no go see the bad Friends
tour go to badfriendspod.com for all the
dates we're coming to 33 cities if we're
not if your City's not on the list it's
probably going to be added so stop
freaking out at Us online yeah
transpod.com for the bad Friends tour
Cheetos Santino and Instagram and
Twitter and keep keep going to see uh
Steve live so he can learn that his fans
are there forever and they're not just
gonna need him for right now so he has
some confidence about it and stops
feeling concerned about their desire for
me than just the uh fiat currency
becoming worthless and the world being
like uh well dude the world is going to
collapse so just strap in yeah
we're gonna make epic content that's
right all right dude I love you man I
love you brother
that was rad did you by the way how did
you guys get you guys get in touch with
them and say we need the conference room
and they were cool about it these people
yeah we just showed up and they said
well we haven't used the conference room
since the pandemic and we're like great
so it's uh available beat cam tail slate
they've been pretty cool it's been it's
been so weird though how about that
ladies and gentlemen I just want to
check in with you guys I'm now in New
Zealand I I have not been home for just
about an entire month and to say that
I'm fried would be an understatement I'm
uh my whole team we're out here like uh
over dying uh excited to get home that
is for sure and um excited about this
podcast it was a long time coming I know
this one's gonna do well I know you guys
had to have just enjoyed it please do do
the thing where you show some love to Mr
Cheeto Santino I would love it if you
guys would post something tag him let
him know that that you enjoyed it maybe
tell them to eat shy that's
s-h-i-y and of course I love you guys I
love you so much thank you for sticking
around yeah dude